morbius is a marvel character who's been
an important part of the universe
he's brilliant i'm cure
it's finally possible he's strong
he's got some unique powers
but his powers seem to be out of his
control
what's happening
i love the opportunity to do something
transformational i've become something
different
it was a very intense physical role
more bias that is most frail and then
most monstrous
this superhero super villain
putting a new marvel character on screen
that had never been on screen before and
it'll be fun to see where we could go
with that there's a web of opportunity
more bs exclusively in movie theaters
new trailer tomorrow